Today.
I have a very special guest.
His name is John [inaudible] and he's an award winning lecturer at the
University of Toronto.
Then the newspapers,
I'm also interested in try to get all the platonic stuff and the neoplatonic
stuff and and,
and,
and make use of that to try and reconfigure a world view in which the
cultivation of wisdom and self transcendence and virtue makes both intellectual
and existential sense to us.
He has an amazing series on youtube called Buddhism and cognitive science.
He coauthored a book titled Zombies in Western Culture
and so the Zombie,
you know,
the way they move in horror,
the shuffling boards without there being any shared communication or culture.
It's,
it's the Dar nightmare side of cut.
We sometimes feel like we're shuffling through the streets with all of these
strangers around us
and he has a new series being released now on awakening from the meaning crisis.
I don't want to build my audience on the back of controversy.
Politicizing these issues.
Thinking that are issues of the conflict of political ideologies is something I
wanted deeply undermining because that is spice sweet.
One of the things driving the meaning question.
John is doing some amazing work.
I felt very lucky to speak with him and I hope you guys enjoy,
um,
I thought we could start by discussing some of your background and education and
how that has led you to this topic of meaning,
which is so central to your work.
Sure,
sure.
Um,
so,
uh,
I started out,
I was doing a Ba in Hamilton at McMaster and I just,
I took a philosophy course when I got very interested.
Um,
I read the republic by Plato.
I got very interested in the topic of wisdom and this quest for meaning in life.
And by that time in my own personal life,
I was post religious.
I'd been brought up,
um,
and sort of a,
a,
a very sort of fundamentalist Christian,
uh,
upbringing.
And I was sort of post doc and I was looking around and initially I got very
interested in what was going on,
but as it went on an academic philosophy,
although I saw its value and I went on to get phd and everything,
um,
and how it helps us better understand science.
And culture,
the whole Platonic Aristotelian quest for wisdom and in life and self
transcendence was not being discussed very adequately in academic philosophy.
So I started,
I started to do stuff extra curricular,
which I've continued to this day.
I did,
I learned to tie Chitwan I learned,
uh,
the past,
the meditation,
met contemplation,
a bunch of other practices,
printing,
Ammo,
yoga and I do all that.
I teach some of it extra curricular and that,
and then I felt this big disjunct between,
I'm doing all these sort of wisdom cultivation practices over here and I have
all this academic stuff.
So then I decided to find how can I put them together.
So I went back and I,
I,
I did a bsc in cognitive science to get the scientific training.
And then I went on and did more of that.
And then I went into cognitive science.
And by that time it's just one of those weird synchronicities,
the field that started to catch up field and people in cognitive science,
cognitive psychology.
Those are my two areas of specialty.
Do,
we'll do a lot of work and wisdom,
meaning all this stuff.
So a lot of your work has been connecting the,
the practical stuff you do in martial arts and all the,
all the education you've had.
Yeah.
So I know,
I think I heard in one of your classes that you,
you said you went to school for 17 years.
Is that,
is that right?
Well I went to,
well I went to university,
I went to university for 17 years because you need to get very good expertise
and one of the core disciplines.
So I ha I basically I had done like I had got up to my ama in philosophy so I
got quite a bit of expertise in that and that's when I,
as I mentioned,
I realized I really wanted to do cognitive science so that I went back into the
cognitive science and then I went back and did my phd.
And so adding in that whole other undergraduate degree,
uh,
and then uh,
a longer phd cause I was integrating stuff together that really add up.
I hadn't quite a bit onto it to philosophy.
That was kind of your first interest,
right?
That was my first interest.
Yeah.
Okay.
Cause this is right when I started reading Plato and Aristotle and all these
philosophers is right when I came across your videos and you had some of the
best explanations cause you know,
that's not the easiest thing to jump right into.
Yeah.
Oh thank you.
I mean I,
I've been privileged to teach at UFT for I guess what is it,
25 years now.
And so,
you know,
these are really bright people where I'm getting to work with.
So I've got,
I've got is afforded me in an arena in which I could really practice refining,
explaining these ideas.
Um,
and so I really appreciate that opportunity because I think these ideas are,
are really pertinent and relevant to many people today and making them
accessible and making them sort of vibrant again for people.
That was one of the things that I consider my important,
what am I important goals.
So a lot of the courses that builds up to,
to Buddhism and you talk a lot about practice practices of mindfulness and how
people can integrate that in their lives.
And there was something really interesting you said about mindfulness,
that there's something we get wrong in the west and that is how we interpret the
Buddhist notion of suffering.
And that was a really interesting point.
I was wondering if you could expand on that a little bit.
Sure,
sure.
Uh,
so,
uh,
part of the argument
is that we've typically understood suffering as the experience of pain.
Um,
and although there are metaphors in the Buddhist pictures where pain is used,
uh,
to talk about the suffering,
that's not the most common metaphor.
The two most common metaphors are imprisonment,
trapped,
fettered locked,
stuck and diseased,
right?
And,
and
so I thought,
oh,
well,
what's being emphasized there?
And this is our actually the original meaning of our word software.
Like,
which is a loss of agency.
You're giving up,
you're losing your agency so you can actually technically suffered joy.
I mean,
that's not an excuse to the word,
it's an archaic use of the word.
People would go,
what do you mean?
But what it literally means is I've,
oh,
I'm overwhelmed by joy and I sort of lose my agent.
Yeah.
And so this idea of losing agency is much more important because it's much more
directly relevant to what the Buddha claim you said.
You know,
you just like you can get,
no matter where you taste the ocean of tastes,
of salt,
no matter where you dip into my teaching,
it's all about freedom.
Right.
And so the freedom from this loss of agency,
I think is one of the major things.
I think this is part and parcel of the Neo Ferrari.
Nah,
I published an article a couple of years ago on this about the West has really
got sort of very narrow and I think overly superficial understanding of
mindfulness and has misinterpreted and in some pretty fundamental ways.
I talk about this also in the new series talking about the mindfulness
revolution,
and I try and give it a,
a stronger account of what I,
how I think we should understand and interpret mindfulness.
Yeah.
Okay.
And the new series,
the new series is great,
by the way.
I've seen the first two episodes so far.
Thank it's,
it really does a great job on building from the last series.
Yeah.
The hope was to so that people are who the people,
I was trying to split the difference.
I was trying to get it to that.
People who have seen the series will say,
oh,
I get this.
This is familiar.
I can build on it.
But also people coming in from nowhere can watch the new series and it's a
standalone.
So
that's been a tricky balance,
but I think we're getting it right.
I'm working with some really great people who are really helping with the
direction and the editing and the filming and everything.
Yeah,
yeah.
Well it wasn't just the content,
all the editing,
the filming was that everything was great.
Yeah.
Well I really wanted to,
I mean it's common complaints that got into Buddhism and cog psy series is like
the audio and the video because all I did was just set up a camera and put it
on.
Right.
Because I didn't think that much of it.
But I'm one of the most common criticisms is like,
well,
you know,
the content is great,
but the format is crap.
So I really wanted to improve it.
This done well.
That's what everyone on youtube does is like when I first started,
the audio was off.
Like the,
the video wasn't that great and you just kind of learn as you go and get better
and better.
Um,
but so you said you had a religious upbringing?
Yeah,
it was,
it was a Christian.
And so,
um,
I keep an eye on that because I try,
I try to be,
um,
I'm going to put this,
I try to be very respectful.
Uh,
whenever I'm talking about a religious framework and a spa.
And I tried to be especially mindful of Christianity because of course I'm going
to have a,
a sort of bias take on it.
And so I,
that I repeatedly
ours or any practicing Christians in my class if like,
if they're,
if they're being offended by what I'm doing and I consistently get no,
they say no,
it's good.
You know,
sometimes it's challenging,
but I still find it beneficial.
And you're very,
and so that's very important to me as well.
That's good.
And it's,
it's,
it's important I think to have your beliefs challenged like that and to be okay
with it.
And the get used to get used to people doing that cause I think that's,
that's kind of what a university is supposed to do.
Right?
I think so.
I mean,
I,
that's what I would hope.
So.
It's,
um,
it depends what course you read,
but it certainly in the courses I'm privileged to teach people that are coming
in with an expectation,
uh,
both from the content of the course and something of my reputation that these
courses are going to challenge them and sort of fundamental ways.
Yeah.
Right.
So,
yeah,
I grew up in a very strict Christian household and um,
I remember when the Harry Potter series came out,
like I had to hide them from my dad because it was all about like witchcraft and
all this evil stuff.
Right.
And so I was very biased against any part of the Christian worldview for most of
my life.
Um,
until recently I've kind of,
I've kind of found the beauty in Christian symbolism.
Um,
I don't think I could ever go back to it just because of that experience I had.
Yeah.
Say,
if someone asks me what I'm reading,
and I say the Tao Te Ching,
there'll be like,
oh,
okay,
interesting.
But if I said the Bible,
they're like,
oh,
and they kind of,
they kind of have all these preconceived notions about it,
which,
yeah,
I think it's like too personal for a lot of people in the west,
which you make the bridge to Buddhism.
And you said it's a way to bridge that gap.
Well,
that's one of the things I recommend.
I mean,
I,
I'm also,
I mean,
I,
I'm privileged to be in dialogue with,
uh,
some Christians that I really deeply respect Jonathan Pojo,
Paul Vendor,
clay,
right?
Um,
and,
and they bring,
you know,
philosophical profundity and,
um,
and,
and so,
um,
I,
I understand what they're doing,
but,
um,
I think they also appreciate what I'm saying,
that for many people like yourself and I,
that really isn't an option.
And that seems to be something that's growing culturally in the west.
I mean,
the numbers are pretty clear about that.
Um,
and so we need something other,
another sort of set of psycho technologies and practices and institutions and
traditions.
Um,
I've also,
uh,
I mean,
in,
in that series because that was the sort of syllabus content of the course.
It focuses in on Buddhism quite a bit because that's one of the things that
people are reaching to,
to try and bridge between the practice and the science.
Um,
I of course do that in the new series,
but in the new series,
I'm also interested in trying to get some of the,
uh,
pre-christian sort of heritage from the west,
all the platonic stuff and the neoplatonic stuff.
And can we access that
and,
and make use of that to try and reconfigure a world view in which the
cultivation of wisdom and self transcendence and virtue,
uh,
makes both intellectual and existential sense to us.
And that's what I like about the series is you're,
you're,
you're showing how it all works together.
Trying.
Yeah.
And that's what you show with each philosophy.
Are you talking about when you talk about Augustine,
you show how he merged all the worldviews of Asia,
Israel and Greece and the tightness and Plato and all these people.
Yeah.
Because you got to explain why did this stuff take off and why does he become
this like literally civilization building individual,
you know,
medieval civilizations sort of built on Augustine and profound ways and so,
um,
you don't want to trivialize that and you want to take one of you.
I mean,
it's really important to try and we really deeply get into like the worldview
that the people had and what was functioning for them.
Like I really try and we reverse engineered the viability.
What made this viable for people?
And I mean these are,
these are intelligent,
thoughtful,
rational,
reflective,
spiritually d people.
What made this viable for them?
I really want to try to work really hard to reverse engineer that.
How could I,
what would I need to be doing?
What would I need to be practicing?
How would my worldview has to be functioning in order that this could be viable
for me?
And then that's what I try to articulate.
I feel like nowadays we think,
oh,
they were just superstitious.
So it didn't really matter what they believe.
And that's kind of a way of dismissing the,
the whole reason why it was,
it was such,
such a powerful idea.
Exactly.
And,
and,
and the problem with that,
with that dismissal is we tend to,
we're,
we're building all these blinders that prevent us for looking for things that
might be structurally or functionally analogous right now.
Right.
Um,
and,
and the thing is,
I'm not,
I make it clear in both series.
Like I'm not saying we'd go back to these things that this is not a nostalgic
thing,
but it's like if we understand them properly,
that will give us,
when you reverse engineer,
you get the capacity for renewing your engineering.
Like I make something now my pride,
I plead,
I see my project and I hope people don't misunderstand when I use this term.
I mean it respect that I'm trying to salvage everything I can from the
beginning.
Not trying to get in for anyone.
No,
no,
no.
I want to salvage as much as I can from all of this vast heritage and so that we
can appropriate this legacy and,
and retool ourselves for confronting the meaning crisis right now.
And you know,
and you also talked about a lot about,
um,
and the new series,
shamanism and altered states.
And,
um,
do you receive any pushback talking about that in a academic setting?
Um,
a little,
um,
yeah,
so there's,
when we get into like the actually yeah,
the third and fourth,
uh,
video fifth,
there's even more.
Cause that's a lot of work I've been doing.
It depends.
So in one sense,
very strong academic support.
I was invited by Laurie Paul,
who I constantly recommend in both series,
uh,
down to Yale to talk to her class and all stuff like Alex.
So they're like,
wow,
that's,
you know,
that's like,
oh,
that's pretty official academic appreciation.
Right?
But also,
but,
but I've also had within at UFT and have people saying,
oh,
what are you doing?
And I was saying,
well,
like,
this is really important research.
This is why.
And there's lots of people working on it,
so they can't deny that it's scientifically valid.
But yeah,
there's still this like
you get that response from some people and then it's like,
you know what Pete people,
and so my official position,
just to restate it right.
Um,
and if anybody's watching,
they can,
you know,
government people like I am against prohibition on any of any substance because
it doesn't work.
The data on this is really clear.
Like we're going to pay attention to prohibition doesn't work.
It doesn't affect addiction rates.
Right.
And,
and the Kemp,
the chemical dependence model of addiction is more abundant.
So absolutely,
that's not how addiction works.
So justification is,
is obsolete and the data shows it's ineffective southern hand.
I'm against the recreational use of my consciousness,
mind altering drugs because,
right.
This is part of the whole way in which people can enhance self deception and the
cultural project of like really trivializing and dismissing the spiritual and
transformative potential of experiences.
Well,
one of the things he talked about is we had,
we used to have universities,
this is where we get knowledge.
And then we had other places where we'd get wisdom,
the Monistat.
Yeah.
But now there's nowhere that we get wisdom anymore.
That's right.
I love to do that in the class I'll say,
well,
where do you go for,
for information on the Internet?
Where do you go for knowledge?
You know,
the university science,
and then where do you go for wisdom?
And then there's this,
then there's this stony silence.
When I say,
well,
you know,
foolishness is something much more than just ignorance,
right?
Ignorance is just a lack of knowledge.
Where it's foolishness is,
you know,
you're caught up in,
a compelling pattern of self deception and self destruction.
And that requires a lot of intervention.
We know this because this is why we have therapists,
right?
Yeah.
It's unfortunate that we have sort of lost,
I didn't know what to call it,
the cultural commitment to making this a central issue that we,
uh,
aid people in their lives.
We just,
as a culture,
we're not doing that
and we're paying for it,
right?
We,
yeah,
we have mental health crisis.
We have all kinds of,
you know,
deaths of despair on the rise.
We,
we have people,
we have increasing a sense of nihilism and cynicism and our culture.
It's eroding our political institutions that are very rapid rate,
all this kinds of stuff.
We're paying for it very deeply.
Um,
so
about two or three or four years before I did the Buddhism and cog psy series,
so that's what,
2016 so maybe around 2012 or so I was already cracking that argument,
building it in,
cause I'd already been teaching that course for a while,
building that argument and then I realized and it was like,
it was like,
oh,
it's kind of a union inside.
It's like when Putin should be,
there should be a mythological expression of an emerging crisis.
And then it was oh crap.
And that's when the zombies were taking off.
Right.
That's just how it came together.
Jonathan Patio independently came to that realization.
Oh he did?
Okay.
That's interesting.
Yeah,
that's how we actually met.
He independently came to it and then he was giving a talk and he mentioned
he did,
he didn't quite extension,
not just to mention he did it quite extensive,
extensive exposition,
what you think.
And he said,
Oh man,
we got to talk.
And so yeah,
that's how we ended up doing the talk on his,
on his panel.
Oh yeah.
That's interesting that,
that you came to those two conclusions simultaneously.
He talks about how um,
the Zombie is a perversion of the death and resurrection
and Christianity.
And um,
yeah,
that's,
that's probably how he got to that.
And then you make the case in,
in the stuff you talk about how Christianity was the,
was the scaffolding that basically held up our society for so long and still the
Zombie when it,
when it,
um,
perverts that,
that story.
It's like all that history is just being wiped out.
Yeah.
I think that's,
yeah.
So my coauthors and I,
you know,
Christopher must've Pietro and Philip [inaudible] we were talking,
that's why we were,
we were arguing,
right.
That,
um,
it's not just the Zombie,
it's the Zombie apocalypse.
It's the combination.
It's not only a perversion of the resurrection,
right,
which are,
yeah.
Jonathan also talks about,
uh,
we talked about how the apocalypse is a perversion of the Christian notion of
apocalypse,
which is the,
the,
the culmination redemption of all of history.
It gives history all of its meaning.
And of course,
the whole point about apocalypse in the Zombie mythology is it doesn't redeem
the world or it actually,
it just,
it opens into this sort of vapid nothingness,
right.
Going forward and,
and,
and their sense that the world is ending,
but not in any,
any way that's affording redemption or restructuring or changing and,
and so,
yeah.
I,
what we were trying to get on about is that the,
the collapse of this framework,
the
rigor posts,
like the sacred canopy is,
is way more comprehensive.
Uh,
because,
uh,
because if it goes to the metaphor I often use is like,
we have this sort of conceptual grammar by which we sort of think and makes
sense and that that was so interwoven with two things,
sort of the Christian framework and the platonic framework.
And as those have eroded,
right?
Yes.
I mean many people up here,
they're all,
I'm happy to.
I don't believe like you are not right when that Abram or got gets eroded,
we have to replace the grammar.
Even though you've already dispensed with the beliefs.
This is part of what again,
I often repeat those people don't get it when [inaudible] is saying that God is
dead.
That's why.
That's why the madman says it to atheist.
He's not saying it to believers.
He goes into the marketplace and he says it to atheists cause he says you don't
know what you done.
Like you've taken a sponge and you've erased the sky and that we're forever
falling like you.
You like we have to replace what this was doing for us.
We can't just stop believing at the superficial level.
So I'm watching your,
your first series of Buddhism and cognitive science.
It felt like it was kind of building up to Nietzsche.
Yeah,
I was,
I was very excited when he said that.
A lot of your new series and we talk about Nietzsche and young and how they were
going to integrate into it.
Yup.
So I've already done it.
I mean we sort of,
we indicated we have sort of 23 videos,
um,
and I've already done a bit of Nietzsche and one of them sort of laying them
into the history.
And then when I come back at the and talk about the meaning crisis,
we'll say I'm going to do a bigger,
a bigger chunk on him.
So he's going to show up in sort of two places in the new series in a more
substantial way.
Uh,
and part of it again is I want to do more on like what was going on and what's
the central,
I think for me,
what [inaudible] is trying to do,
right?
The central project is he's trying to recover self transcendence within a world
in which,
um,
the two worlds mythology,
the axial revolution mythology has decayed for us and he's struggling to do it,
but I think he's still caught up in a lot of the Christian grammar.
Um,
and,
and he doesn't quite
six,
the Christian grammar,
which is not to escape from it,
it's still to be working within it.
Um,
and so,
and I don't mean this in a,
I don't mean this to be dismissive.
If I about what we need is sort of a post Nietzschean response snuff.
Nietzsche was a great articulator I think of it,
the problem and even even so insofar as indicating some of the things that are
going to be needed for a solution,
but I don't think his solution is the answer kind of.
Okay.
Um,
we talked about the collapse of religious belief and it seems like we kind of,
we project that belief out on to other things that aren't a religion and that's
worked out disastrously,
right?
Yes.
So,
I mean,
it would,
I talked to quite a bit more about this in the new series,
right.
Cause I take the history farther than I did in the Buddhist and Clark Psych
course.
I talk about,
uh,
posttraumatic pseudo religious ideologies,
like not Sikhism and Marxism,
um,
and,
and nationalism,
patriotism,
all these surrogates.
Um,
and even,
um,
even stuff we're doing now,
which is,
you know,
people who are,
I'm not religious and yet they're like obsessed with superhero movies and they
want,
they want,
they try as much as they can to symbolic.
We live in that world and identify with individuals.
And um,
so yeah,
there's a lot of the attempts and and many of them are on nostalgic it critical
sense of that term or attempts to try and replace that grammar.
Uh,
but
did they fail for some very deep reasons.
One of the,
uh,
one of the reasons is many of them are caught within a model,
like a framing of the scientific understanding of the mind that we've largely
inherited from Descartes.
And that's,
that's now the project of philosophy and cognitive science in the last hundred
years has been trying to deconstruct that Cartesian a framework and open us up
to alternatives.
Like one of them is even to think about,
we even use this as a synonym Iti.
Think about religion as a sophisticate has belief as a system of beliefs.
That belief is the primary thing.
We should be like focusing on it.
And so we keep trying to pick ideological responses to the meeting prices
without realizing that it pervades into much deeper levels of the psyche then
are reached by just our,
our,
our sort of introspective or beliefs.
You talk a lot about meaning in life and how that's all been lost to us and our
in our modern world.
Based on your work and maybe like the attitude that you see in your students,
are you optimistic about regaining that meaning?
Yeah.
Okay.
I mean,
so,
well my most days,
but I need,
so again,
one of the things that Topol is meaning in life is such a hot topic now and many
aspects of cognitive science.
It's a hot topic in philosophy,
very hot topic in psychology doing work on it.
My lab,
the consciousness and the wisdom study labs.
We just did a huge m Turk study and we found that there's a significant,
I'd like to know not just statistically significant,
but a significant correlation between,
um,
if people have mystical experience and how meaningful they rate their life.
And then,
and then trying to find out,
okay,
what is it in the experiences sort of doing most of the heavy lifting and in
this lines up with other work by someone's Samantha Hanselman and others that
it's sort of the insight like machinery cognition is sort of this making
coherence making sense,
right?
Um,
that's the level at which you can improve people's meaning in life.
And it,
it,
it's,
it's being able to again,
trigger these kinds of experiences with reliable systems a or technologies that
are set within an intellectually and culturally validated,
right.
Um,
worldview and framework that I think is doable for us now because I think,
I think all the pieces,
there's so many good people doing work on all of the pieces and we're,
we're making pretty significant understanding and all the components and there
is great.
And on the other side,
right,
there's great cultural hunger for all of this stuff.
And so I see this confluence picking up speed.
Now I'm not,
I'm not,
I think there's,
I don't believe in destiny or anything like that.
And this can all go wrong in many ways because we're in a,
we're in a very tight race.
Cars trying to get this addressed is,
is meshed up with other horrible things we're facing in our culture.
Like there's political,
socioeconomic,
environmental issues that are pressing on us in a very urgent manner.
We talked about the,
the showman too,
and it seems like just in the last maybe five to seven years,
there's been a rediscovering of the showman and trying to get back to wisdom as
you talk about.
Nope.
Again,
I think that's there.
There's again,
there's good and bad about that.
The fact that the,
that your tip,
right?
So they're like,
this is a mythological attempt to try and get back before there's history so
that we can,
and I think there's sort of like,
I don't want to call it they're avocado,
but this sort of semi conscious understanding of it,
we've got to somehow get back,
uh,
to this machinery that's been layered over.
And I respect that.
And then the idea that,
you know,
altered states of consciousness,
uh,
and transformative experiences play an integral role in a self transcendence.
And self transcendence itself plays an integral role in the cultivation of
wisdom.
You really can't overcome pervasive self deception unless you're doing powerful
self transcendence.
Those two are just locked like this together.
I think that all is very good.
The problem we have,
and this is,
I think you noticed this in the,
in the old series and it's in the new series as well,
is our culture tends to commodify and trivialize things and displace them from
an ecology of practices.
Like again,
too many people that just sort of taking shamanism and then all just practice it
on my own as somebody in North America in the year 2019 and that has no problem
is from something that you know is from the Upper Paleolithic era right now.
Others like come on that,
that you have to pay attention to.
Like what?
Like that.
So yeah.
Well yeah,
there's like this Hubris and thinking you can do something on your own that has
this thousands of years of history behind it and you're like,
ah,
I'm good.
I can just,
I can do it on my own.
Exactly.
And,
and,
and so this is part of the problem we face,
right?
There's a bit of a,
you know,
a cult of individualism that we've inherited in the west.
Uh,
uh,
you know,
and this,
again,
this is part of the Christian heritage.
The Christian heritage tended to give us the sense of the value of the
individual because if it's mythology of the individual soul that was destined to
return to God and,
and I,
and that has had a lot of positive benefits for us,
but we have tended to come to this idea of the completely self reliant self made
individual,
which is a mythology,
right?
There are just so many ways in which that's not true of us.
In fact,
one of the exciting things that's going on in cognitive science right now is to
understand how much brains work in networks in what's called distributed
cognition.
Most of our problem solving has done long before the Internet network computers
together,
their culture was networking brains together because most of our significant
problem solving is done by networking brands.
And I'm like,
look at the language you're using.
You didn't make it.
I didn't make it right.
Uh,
this technology,
I didn't make it.
You didn't make it
there.
Yeah.
And so you can't sort of leap out of all of that into a sort of raw and rugged
individualism.
Um,
now everybody please,
that's different from the moral argument that we all have to bear it individual
responsibility for actions.
I'm not denying that I'm making a point.
I'm making a dip and part of it,
but my point is we shouldn't confuse the fact that we are individually morally
responsible with the fact that our cognition often works in a distributed
fashion.
So do you think it's,
um,
taking individual responsibility but doing
that within a culture and within a community?
Exactly.
Very well put.
That's very welcome.
Yeah.
And one of the big things you've talked about in the,
the,
the book on zombies is that we're surrounded by each other,
but completely isolated at the same time.
Yeah.
Go ahead.
Oh No,
you go ahead.
I was just gonna say it and then this Ami just captures that and reflect,
I mean,
the point about myth,
right,
is to reflect back.
I mean it's to transform it and it's through imagery and reflect it back to us
so that we can gain some awareness and insight.
And so the Zombie,
you know,
the way they move in hoards the shuffling boards without there being any shared
communication or culture.
It's,
it's,
it's the dark nightmare side of how we,
how we sometimes feel like we're shuffling through the streets with all of these
strangers around us.
Um,
yeah,
sure.
Yeah.
So I think it's interesting you used the word reflection and myth has a
reflection of,
um,
of these patterns that were playing out.
And a lot of people take myth as just,
Oh,
a,
a fairytale,
you know,
something that's not true,
then I'll leave.
So that's an unfortunate,
a negative consequence of the enlightenment.
I don't mean Buddhist enlightenment to,
I mean,
in period in Western history called the enlightenment,
you know,
the 16th,
the 16th and 17th centuries,
right?
Early 18th century in which,
you know,
there's the,
there's the scientific revolution.
Uh,
there's the development of,
uh,
of,
of a completely secular state.
Um,
there's the industrial revolution.
All of these things are coordinating together.
Um,
and
so,
and there was a project of trying to understand everything before that as you
know,
superstitious or inaccurate or incomplete or,
or something like that.
And I think that has led us to misunderstand myth.
And the problem is the misunderstanding is on sort of
both sides of the debate.
People who see them like so the,
the,
the point about,
like I said,
the point of what myth is and to give us literal stories about some past
something that actually happened.
Um,
and so I think fundamentalism is very much the same mindset,
uh,
applied to the miss as the people who reject myths because right now,
and so the point of a myth and the reason why the myth persists and not on this
persist,
they die.
Right?
And that tells you that they aren't being judged in terms of their literal truth
or falsity.
They're being judged in terms of how they resonate with us,
how they perform,
this reflective function of putting us in contact with sort of perennial
problems that are very hard to keep in mind.
Very hard.
I need to think about the fact that many of the things that you really are,
I do this in the lecture so you get familiar with this,
but many of the things that we very value,
it's very hard to hold in mind like holding justice in mind is very high.
We need a symbol,
we need a myth,
and then if you can tell the story around the symbol,
it becomes more efficacious.
And if there's a story you can put yourself into sort of a participation,
you can get involved.
And so what miss do is they help us right there about these perennial problems,
these perennial patterns,
and they give us ways of holding these otherwise difficult things in mind and
involving ourselves with them.
That's very,
very powerful.
That's why people want to be zombies.
That's why they,
they go on these Zombie walks and you've had,
why aren't you doing this?
What's it going off of it?
Well,
a lot of religions,
they focus on ethics and being a good person.
And you were saying like,
why do I need a story to tell me how to be a good person?
But it's like you say,
it's hard to hold that in your mind all the time because like I know it takes it
what it takes to be a good person.
But when you go into your life and you're faced with problems,
right?
You,
you act on instinct and you don't,
you don't,
you don't think about that.
That's right.
This,
this is,
this is people who say this,
uh,
the point you just made us,
you know,
what do I need a story for it?
Let's split.
We cut because I mean your,
your autobiographical memory abilities or something that you don't,
aren't natural to you.
You like,
look,
we practice narrative all the time.
Like every,
every we get up and we read stories and we look stories.
And when you meet somebody,
you tell them your story.
And if I ask you who you are as a person,
not as a biological organism,
but who you are as a person,
you tell me your autobiography.
And when you're watching the news and you don't know the story,
well why did that happen?
You get all upset.
But when a story get is going to go,
you relax.
Because stories are how we actually create that autobiographical sense of
ourselves extended in time into the past and future.
I had to talk more about this in the new series.
And so like no stories are,
again,
they're,
they're part of the grammar of your agency as a person,
as a moral agent.
Right.
So that's why stories matter.
Yeah.
And one thing I love about your work is it's very grounded in science.
Like you talk a lot about the science of the mind,
but it's also,
it's very focused on the human experience and you focus on that aspect.
Is that something you,
you make a point to focus on?
And I think that's why your,
your talks are so captivating.
Thank you.
Uh,
thank you for saying that because that's exactly right.
For me,
bridging between those is a,
an explicit and constant goal.
What are used to guide me,
uh,
what I'm trying to do,
my work really trying to get right,
uh,
the science and the experience really,
really well wedded together so that they're mutually informing each other.
Um,
yeah,
that,
that's like the North Star of my work and farms and we orienting towards that.
And one you talk about is
I'm a very pivotal moment and,
uh,
our history,
which is Descartes,
right?
You talk about one of his contemporary spinosa and how different our world could
have been,
um,
if,
if we had followed the principles of Spinosa instead of Descartes.
I was already,
if you could talk about that a little bit,
how,
how different it could have been.
Okay,
yeah,
sure.
I mean,
so that's where this gives me a chance to advertise for us,
but knows it is going through something of a renaissance now.
Um,
at least within academic philosophy,
there's a growing appreciation of his relevance,
how relevant he is now to us.
So the thing that was just a very,
very quick thing up or,
so who is he?
Right.
And so I spinosa east,
he's a contemporary of Descartes off.
So he,
he,
he is a big fan of and is like in meshed with the new emerging science.
And so one of the things that happens with the partners,
we get mathematics wedded to science.
Aristotelian science has no math in it.
And so you get math as the quarter science and mathematical reasoning.
And so spinosa is,
he is baker to genius,
but Spinosa is too,
he hit his ability to like mathematically logically reason is to pass when you
read his book,
the ethics.
But remember that title when you read his book,
the ethics,
it is like reading Euclid's geometry and it's,
you know,
axiom roof aren't,
I'm not saying it's absolutely flawless,
but man,
talk about something that is logically logically rigorous,
right?
So you get all of what was being valued in the Cartesian revolution.
Black and this is the important point.
It's called the ethics because it's about not just their new scientific world
view.
It's about how can I recover,
right?
A sense of sacredness,
blessedness,
self-transcendence wisdom,
these are all terms spinosa is really key to talk about within and completely
consistent with that scientific method.
So for me Spinosa is like,
yet that's part of the endorsed star I was talking about.
He was trying,
we didn't add them together.
And when you read the ethics,
it's not just the content,
the way it's the way it's designed,
it,
it's really transformative on your cognition.
It's like going through like almost like,
I don't mean in terms of content,
but the effect it has on you.
It's like going through a meditation course.
It's not just changing what you believe,
it's changing how you think and how you see.
Right.
And so if we,
if he,
if that had been more central right,
then the project of keeping the two together would have been more central for us
and that,
that would probably have led to a very different place than where we are now.
Yeah.
Cause Descartes kind of does away with all that stuff.
He said the only thing that's real is this small slice of consciousness that I
can prove 100% exists.
Okay.
Yeah.
And would they also with Descartes,
right.
Uh,
I mean he,
he,
he done,
I'll get into passions and stuff.
Is He is interested.
Uh,
we're trying to help people sort of develop,
uh,
and,
and I think his whole project is a response to,
uh,
the,
the emergence of the meaning crisis with the emergence of the scientific
revolution.
But I think he fundamentally misunderstood it.
So,
I mean,
I,
I don't,
I'm not,
I don't like it when people blame Descartes for everything.
But,
uh,
I'm not saying you said that either.
Um,
I think Descartes gets the existential anxiety and dread and it's going on.
I mean,
it's one of his contemporaries.
Pascal says,
you know,
the infinite spaces terrify me,
right?
Descartes gets that.
But Descartes thinks the way that will alleviate anxiety is by pursuing
certainty.
And he thinks that what the new math and the science is going to give us a
And,
and what we've discovered through the history of science,
right?
And the philosophy of science,
it's not,
science doesn't give you certainty.
In fact,
that's what,
what's valuable.
It's science isn't the content being certain cause it never is.
It's that the process is so fantastically and elegantly self correcting what
matters.
Right?
And so,
and I think Spinosa sees that way better than daycare.
Way,
way better.
Okay.
And so I know you talked a lot about practices.
We need the,
we need the knowledge,
but we also need the practices in our lives.
And you're,
you're a martial artist,
right?
Yup,
Yup.
Yeah.
We'll kind of martial arts.
Do you do
like I do touch each one and that's the primary one.
I do different persons of it.
There's a slow form I do.
I also do a fast biking,
Fordham fault.
The Gin,
I do a sword form as well.
Okay,
cool.
Yeah.
I'm so I've done in Jujitsu for a long time.
Just as a side,
this is anecdotal,
I haven't done any scientific investigation on it.
So take it with a big grain of salt.
Right.
A lot of people who come to my work,
I often have kind of a martial art.
Right.
So I think that gives them a way of understanding some of the stuff I'm talking
about it.
Yeah.
Well a lot of the stuff you talk about in like states of flow,
like you definitely experienced that.
And so there's this instructor,
his name is John Danaher,
and he had a really interesting way of describing why Jujitsu in martial arts
are so addicting.
It's such an addicting practice.
And he says that we are complex,
unique problem solvers,
but in Jujitsu we're not being presented with a static problem.
We're being presented with another complex and unique problem solver.
So I give this person a problem,
they solve it,
they give a problem back to me and it just goes back and forth like that.
Yeah.
That was a really interesting,
uh,
a point that he made.
I think that's an excellent point.
That's why the,
that's why other people are the best flow inducers for us.
Yeah.
You want to get into flow state the best,
the best video games are coming close.
Right.
Uh,
but the best thing is,
is like some kind of cooperative competitive thing with another human being.
Yeah.
Um,
so you also talk about mindfulness practices a lot and that's,
maybe I misunderstood this,
but I think,
I believe you're saying that by practicing mindfulness you can make that flow.
Um,
more of your default state.
You get closer and closer to making it.
Oh,
totally,
totally.
I mean that's,
I need that.
That was a claim made way back when in 1990 when she sent my,
I did the book on flow.
He,
she talks about the sort of environmental conditions that are conducive to
float,
but he says,
what are those sort of,
what's the skillset of the person,
uh,
and that is more likely to get into flow.
And mindfulness training is one of the best predictors of your ability to get
into the flow state.
And we actually talked about that.
Um,
uh,
Leo and uh,
Erin,
uh,
Leo for our area here,
a Bennett and uh,
we published a,
an article last year and the Oxford handbook of spontaneous thought on flow and
we tried to argue about the deep con like arguing,
explained since the deep connections between mindfulness insight flow.
And they all had to do with sort of how you're learning to discipline your
attention so that you can restructure what you find relevant and salient,
but you have to learn how to do this,
optimize you're saying.
And this really complex,
sophisticated manner.
When the environment you're doing dealing with is also complex.
Yeah.
Environment's constantly changing.
Is that accurate?
And when you talk about Phil,
you also mentioned rock climbing on that,
which there's this new movie,
I don't know if you've seen it.
It's called freecell though.
No.
Oh Man.
It's amazing.
It follows this guy,
Alex tunneled and he goes to some of the most dangerous walk rock walls in the
world.
And he climbs without a rope.
Oh yeah.
So it's still crazy.
It's just one step or one tiny finger hold is the difference between life or
death.
So just the,
the state of mind you'd have to get in to do something like that.
And so the,
in one of the scenes,
they,
um,
they scan his brain and they show that he has almost no activation in his
amygdala.
And so this thing is not so much that he doesn't feel fear,
but it takes a much more,
um,
a much higher stimulus than a normal person.
And so I thought that was kind of an interesting point.
Like,
whether you can,
whether he was born with that or whether it was a thing that was trained over
doing these dangerous things for so many years.
It's hard to say.
I mean it's always GBV sorts.
That's mean.
It's always genetic environment interacting like the old,
the old nature nurture debate,
such genes.
It seemed more abundance,
like the two are locked together and just really,
really complex interaction.
So you probably had,
he was probably constitutionally born with some dispositions,
but there was also stopping early upbringing things base.
But he also is probably cultivators trying to trace like trying to find that the
silver bullet point of that now.
Yeah.
So,
but one thing I think is,
is,
is very,
um,
we can have confidence in saying is that extended training and skills is
definitely a rewinder and cause brain and powerful and important ways.
I mean,
that's what practice does.
It,
it taps into the,
of your brain in important ways.
Okay.
So your book zombies in Western civilization,
that was one of the most disturbing books I've ever read.
Um,
and I mean that in a good way.
Like,
I feel like you need those,
those experiences where,
um,
you like have that existential crisis.
And do you think,
you'd probably say that in our modern world we already are alienated,
but do you think we kind of need to realize that alienation before we can start
to move through it?
I think so.
I mean,
again,
the is tried to wake us up to the realization in mythology isn't doing the
theoretical work,
but it's,
it's,
it's a,
it's a cycle technology you've designed to wake us up to the realization what
are the,
the interesting things that many people,
other people,
cause there's a lot of people that are converging on this idea,
right?
I'll also be going to mean for us as Charles Taylor's talk to you about it with
the Malays and maternity,
right.
You know,
young even talked about it way back when,
but he did modern man in search of a soul right there.
So there's a lot of different people converging on this.
But one of the things is often is that the deadening nature of the meaning
crisis can often sort of make people superficially on aware of how much it is
pervading their life.
So they tend to,
they tend to only come into awareness of it when they get things that reveal
sort of the fragility and the lack of resilience they have to dealing with,
uh,
you know,
issues of self,
deception,
self destruction,
right.
A lack of connectedness to other people not having a world view that can help
them deal with their own suffering and distress.
Right.
All that.
I think you're doing some very important work and I'm,
I'm glad that you stopped here to talk with us today.
Um,
and one of your contemporaries is Jordan Peterson at the University of Toronto.
Right.
And so he kind of got famous after getting caught up in that gender pronoun
issue.
Um,
have you ever thought about just getting embroiled in a personal scandal to get
your ideas out there?
Um,
yeah.
I'm not in the sense that I've considered it,
but people have proposed it to me.
And,
um,
I hope,
I mean,
Jordan and I have debated and we've been to conferences together.
I mean we used to talk fairly regularly.
Um,
and,
and so I,
I,
I don't want to easily dismiss or,
or say anything about,
I mean,
he's a complex guy and there's lots of,
I think he's really,
I think you're right.
Part of his famous is controversy and he,
he makes some practice of saying controversial stuff on a regular basis.
Traversal.
I get that.
Right.
Uh,
but I think,
I think it's fair to say because that doesn't explain all of his success.
He puts his finger on the meeting crisis.
There's a reason,
you know,
we shared so many students and we often appeared at conferences together because
we're both concerned in different ways about the meaning crisis.
So I,
I acknowledge that however,
and,
and I,
I mean,
I have,
I,
I would,
I'd like,
I'd like to debate in the good sense to talk with them again in public about
responding to the meaning crisis.
Cause there's points of his work that I agree with.
There's points of his work that I disagree with.
And our last conversation I think was really sort of good about that.
But I don't want to build my audience on the back of controversy.
Right.
And,
and,
and it's not just because that's sort of who I am as a person,
but it's also that we talked about this earlier,
politicizing these issues,
thinking that are issues of the conflict of political ideologies is something I
want to deeply undermine because that is sys Lee.
One of the things driving the meaning crisis,
the idea,
we can frame this and resolve it as a clash of political ideologies is exactly
something,
a presupposition.
I want to fundamentally excavate and dispose of it because that is something you
significantly contributing to the meaning crisis.
So it would,
it would feel deeply hypocritical for me to try and build my reputation on the
back of a political controversy.
Yeah.
Yeah,
that's a very good point.
And I know with Jordan,
he didn't do it on purpose,
right?
He got Kinda got swept up in the controversies and that kind of,
that exposed a lot of people to his ideas that he was already putting out for a
long time.
And I think that's a good point though that um,
it doesn't seem like a lot of those topics do add to the polarization so people
don't actually listen to you.
It's like you say your point,
they say their point and no one's really,
no one's really making any ground.
They're listening to each other.
That's why I really like,
I like the discussion I had with Jordan.
I really,
really like the discussion that I had with Jonathan about that because you know,
Jonathan and I,
we differ in some fundamental ways.
He's a practicing Christian.
I'm not,
I mentioned it but there was so,
so much mutual respect and so much,
how can we talk about this,
like a Socratic and platonic fashion and you know,
and I would be happy to talk with Jonathan again at any point.
I think we mutually enjoyed it.
We've mutually beneficial.
He came to Toronto not that long ago and we had lunch together.
I mean it's,
that's,
that's what we need to be doing more of.
Yeah.
Those,
those uh,
productive talks instead of just the back and forth.
Um,
and Jonathan Patio,
I really liked his channel because he comes from a perspective of a practicing
Christian,
which I don't think I'm ever going to return to something like that,
you know,
so it's,
it's from a perspective,
but he makes it accessible to everyone.
Christian symbolism that most people wouldn't take seriously.
He kind of makes it,
makes it relevant to people.
Totally.
I need,
Jonathan is philosophically astute and he is very open to considering,
you know,
arguments and points other than and framework.
He sees the value,
I think of other philosophical and religious framework and I don't think that's
false.
I think he genuinely sees the value.
But what's also important for me,
you know,
I often say,
this is a slogan.
Don't tell me what you believe.
Telling me what you practice and see,
Jonathan has a practice and his art,
his art,
it's not even a good enough word,
but he's art as a sacred practice for him.
It's really a sacred practice for him.
Like he's got a deep and profound practice.
And I,
and I really,
really respect that and that,
that,
that needs,
you know,
even,
even though we made different disagree about things we've got,
we've,
there's depth there that we can,
we can draw upon in conversation and I find it very valuable to do so.
Okay.
Wow.
Great.
Well,
thank you John for coming here today.
Um,
and I feel like this is a great conversation.
I really enjoyed it.
Thank you very much.
It's been a pleasure to meet you.
I really enjoyed it and I just want to stop now and say,
um,
you know,
thank you.
Uh,
for the,
the videos.
I mean,
they're so well done and thank you.
They're,
they're simultaneously intellectually rigorous and entertaining and you know,
and you're doing this and like 15 minutes things just,
this is really,
really cool.
And I know a lot of my students and my viewers,
when they see it,
they're just,
they're really appreciative of it.
Thank you man.
I mentioned it to my coauthors.
I mentioned that to Chris and Phillip and they were both like,
wow,
these are great.
These are big as a
thank you man.
I really appreciate that.
Well,
there was so much,
there's so much source material to work with.
You guys did all the legwork and I,
my,
I felt like my job was just to try and condense it into something that people
could watch in one sitting,
you know,
and trying to keep it as true to the source material as I could.
So I'm glad that makes me very glad that you enjoyed it.
You're succeeding admirably out though.
You just succeeding admirably,
so thank you.
Thank you.
Um,
so where can people find you?
Ah,
so the,
the,
the best thing is,
um,
I,
if they want to,
they can just email me if they want to engage in email conversation,
Don docker naked you mail.com or they can just,
I mean,
if they want to see all this stuff,
just go on to my youtube channel,
but I got a youtube channel and
John,
Jennifer,
Vicky,
right.
That has all the,
all your lectures and talks in there.
All of it.
And it's all playlisted.
That's where the new video series is being released.
It's all there.
Ready to go?
Okay.
Anything else you want to promote or talk about?
Um,
there's more books coming out.
There's two books going to be coming out this year.
Chris and I are looking at working on the follow up book to the Zombie Book.
Um,
it's called,
um,
unsheltered.
It's about the whole genealogy of where we lose the sacred canopy and the west
and what does that mean for us?
And then something somewhere we were talking about today.
And then there's a book I'm working on with,
um,
with,
uh,
Daniel Craig and had a toy and it's called the cognitive continuum from insight
to enlightenment.
A all about what I was,
how there's this,
there's these insight experiences,
flow experiences,
a psychedelic experiences,
awakening experiences,
enlightened experience,
and trying to break cognitive science to that and make sense of it in a coherent
fashion.
So those are both coming up this year.
Okay.
Awesome,
man.
I look forward to all of that.
Okay.
All right.
Well,
thank you.
Thank you.
You too.